[音楽]
[拍手]
では
反らせていただきます
こんにちは高橋
英明でございます
72歳です
この
会場ではですね
多分最年長のことだそうです
今日はですね皆さんに私のですね
拙い人生からですね
切り入れるメッセージをお伝えいたします
よろしくお願いします
私はですね今
喫茶店の
研修をしております
前職はですね
警察官でした
警察官として
警視庁に
努めている間
自分の中にある思いがありました
もし自分がいなかったら困る
社会を作りたい
もちろんあの
警察官をですねここ出したのは
社会のためになりたいとそう思ったからで
ございます
しかし
警察
官をして
勤めるうちにですねある思いが湧きました
軽症ではですねある意味
多数の中の一人でしかなかったということ
ですね
何せ5万人もいる中でございます
例えば
自分一人がいなくなっても
組織的には
ほとんど何も変わらない
自分でなくてもいいと
しかしですね
自分で何かを経営するということになり
ますとまずどうしてもいなくてはならない
ということでこの
道を選びました
回転した通りですね
地域では大型天皇ですね出店が相次ぎまし
て
さらにものをですね仕入れて売るだけでは
小さな会社では
太刀打ちできることは
難しくなりました
ですから
料理というですね
味付けを
して
付加価値をつけて売ることで勝負いたし
ました
お客さんのですね
側にの気持ちに立つということでござい
ます
経営しておりますとどうしてもですね
利益がなくてはならないですから
どうしてもあの経営者目線の立場で
利益を考えてしまう
その時ですね私の
奥さんがですねお客さんがに立って仕事を
してくれたと
どうしたらですねお客さんが気持ちよく
過ごしてくれるだろう
またどうしたら
満足してもらえるだろうまあそう私とは
ですね全く違う目線で考えてくれました
これが
非常に良かったのだと今思っております
あとはですね人材
育成でしょうか
店にはですね
傾斜の石を
与えている人に
体現してもらわなくてはなりません
人間はですねそう思うにはなりません
多分ですね皆さんもアルバイトしたことが
あると思うんですがお客さんのことをです
ね
第一に考えて
多分いないと思うんですね
時給はいくらかなとか時間がどうだとか
早くわかりたいなとかじゃないかなと思っ
ております
それをですねお客さんのためにという
気持ちになってもらうまこれがですね
難しいけれども大事なことなんでござい
ます
[音楽]
回転者のはですねだいたい
昭和54年の頃でした
ちょっとされたですね
木星の
木枠の
地蔵浦を取り入れまた
赤いですね絨毯を敷き詰めましてもちろん
エアコンも設置しました
最初はですね
先進的すぎて
前には反対されました
時にはですね
絨毯の前で
靴を脱いでしまうお客さんまで出ました
今ではですねそんなことは考えられません
が
他にもですね
回転
当時
近隣地域ではですね非常に珍しかった
ピザ屋
ドリアあるいはラザニアですかそれと
スパゲティなどのメニューを出しました
だからこれはですねあの
喫茶店というよりも
幼少洋食屋さんですね
ですがこれがですね1日
約200名のですね来客来客を読みこれ
まで40年以上続くお店になりました
この業界ではですね20年続く店は
約5%
ほどだと聞いたことあります
新しいものをですね
取り入れるのはいつだって挑戦でござい
ます
ですが
朝鮮学習ですね続けることはできません
この町がですね
好きだったんですね
皆さんは自分の街が好きですか
私がですね
再開発の
理事長として関わったのはですね
東京都の
地図で言いますとほぼ真ん中にあります
郊外の
街小平という市のですね中心とも言える
駅小川駅でございます
日本の電車がですねここに停車いたしまし
て
近くにもですね
多くの学校もあり
非常にのどかでありながら
賑やかな面を持つ
駅でございます
この駅ではですね
次の世代のためにですね小屋
孫の世代のためにのまちづくりですねが
必要でございました
様々なですね
部分が
老朽化しこれからもですね
続いていくには
様々なところを
新しくしなくてはなりませんでした
特にですね
東日本大震災の時はこの駅でもですね
帰宅困難者が多く発生しました
だから
災害へのですね
強さというものもですね
必要でございました
武蔵野のですね
面影や
地域の歴史
文化を残すこともまたですね
近隣の
老人ホームや障害者の学校ですね
そういう人たちの利便性も考えました
しかしこの駅だけが
再開発されるわけではありません
小平という
町そのものをですね
次の世代へつなげていく
新しい街に
変えていこうという
プランがありました
まちづくりという大きなですね
プランの中の一つがこの再開発です
この街がですね
非常に好きだからこそどうやってですね
周りの人に
好きになってもらうか
そのためにですね
地域の
活性化が
強く不可欠でございましたこれがですね
市内
始まって以来のですね初めての民間による
再開発の発端でございます
そうですね一見1件を回ってですね
参戦を
得ることですね
まずは
再開発はですねどういうものかをですね
理解してもらうのが大変でした
実は
区画整理とですね災害発は違うんですね
これをですねうまく理解してもらうのが
難しかったですね
ただ単にあの駅前にですね
ロータリーを作って
タクシーが止まりバスが通るだけの
災害じゃないんですね
まず生活基盤を整え
商業施設やですね
要請してそれ
病院
託児所置き
そうしてですね
生活しやすいような街に
整備するこれが
再開発です
もちろんですね
反対意見もありました
ですがですね
誰もこの地区がですねこのままでいいと
いうことは思っていませんでした
先ほども申し上げましたが
東日本大震災でこの地区に大量の帰宅困難
者が発生しました
バスがないこと
タクシーがないこと
安全にですね人が歩ける道がない
活気のある
商店街がない
痒まる品をその揃えられることができない
文化がないこの町をですね
みんな
好きになってもらいたいからこそですね
様々な今まで行った内容ですねある意味
変えるがこの再開でした
ある日ですね
近所の小学校その時多分5年生だったと
思いますが
理想の街についてですね話す機会があり
ました
そうしますとこの災害スプランの目標と
同じことをですね
生徒たちが言ってくれるんですね
文化を残したい
緑が欲しい
みんながですね暮らしやすい町がいい
アルコールよく考えてるんですね
自分のお母さんがこの街でパートとして
働く場所が欲しい
その他にもいろんな意見があったんですが
非常に盛り上がりましてそれがですね私の
非常にこの後の励みになりました
子供の意見というものは
損得がございませんだからあのまっすぐな
んですね
そしてまた
子どもたちは行く自分の町を見ているんだ
なと思いました
私はですね今
喫茶店の店主をしております
前職は
警察官でした
仕事っていうのはやってみないと自分に
やってるかどうかわかりませんだからまず
はですねやってみることですね
そしてまた好きだなと思える部分をですね
その中が探すそしてですね夢中になって
ドキドキハラハラすることですねこれは
大切なんじゃないかなと思います
自分にとってですね
面白く生きる方法は誰も教えてくれません
路線図だけじゃない
信号機もですね
交差点も
自分で決めなくてはなりませんどこで
止まるかまたどこで進むかどこでですね
誰と出会い何をするのかそれをですね
全部自分で決めるそうするとねこれがあの
自分のね
非常に人生になるんですねそこがまたいい
と思います
はい最後になりました
僕の人生にはですねたくさんの人との
つながりがありますそのつながりとですね
その中でも
僕とですねお店を支えてくれた私の
奥さんに感謝を申し上げて
投稿終わりにしたいと思いますありがとう
ございました